avec charlie krief il ne fait pas très
beau et sur le plan d'eau les voiles
sont plutôt rares quatre embarcations
seulement mais pour arthur qui
pratiquent cette discipline
régulièrement navigué par petits groupes
est plutôt un avantage ça se passe
comment aujourd'hui à écouter c'est très
calme il n'y a pas beaucoup de pauvres
beaucoup de monde c'est c'est très
agréable pour surtout pour apprendre ça
peut être pas mal
pour encadrer ces jeunes voici aloïs
chaque jour ce jeune homme effectue des
rotations et enseigne la discipline lui
aussi apprécié la navigation par ce
temps un plus pour ses élèves
c'est mieux pour les enfants qui peuvent
justement vu qu'il ya moins de monde on
est plus à leur écoute et c est
voilà pour progresser c'est mieux ouais
pour progresser c'est beaucoup mieux
ces jeunes sont en colonie de vacances à
proximité de l'étang du puits tous
habitent la région
certains ont déjà de l'expérience
d'autres comme clarisse des buts
totalement bas c'est la première fois
donc je voulais tester mollahs aux frais
parce que j'avais jamais fait de bateaux
dans ma vie vous voulez tester la voile
c'est bien pourquoi
bah c'est ça nous apprend c'est amusant
et tout ça pas de leçon ce week-end la
navigation reprendra lundi
d'autres enfants viendront à leur tour
s'initier à la voile sur le plus grand
étant de la sologne